- Communication is one
of the most important
feedback topics in consulting.
If you work for one of the
leading consulting firms
and you get a feedback
conversation with your manager,
it is pretty much clear
that how you communicate
will be one of the key topics
discussed in this conversation.
Hi guys.
My name is Heinrich,
and welcome to my channel Firm Learning.
Thank you for watching again.
Communication is something
that pretty much all consultancies cover
in their onboarding training programs.
Young consultants need to take
dedicated communication classes,
and communication is one of the things
that is discussed most frequently
in feedback conversations
between young consultants and managers.
When I was a young consultant at McKinsey
it was pretty common that
after I was on a call,
after I participated in a client meeting
and maybe said something there,
I would get some feedback
from my project lead
on how I said certain things.
So, of course what you
say is important as well.
And if you said something
that might not be considered
very intelligent or appropriate to say
then yes of course,
this would be addressed
in the feedback sessions.
But at least as likely
you will get feedback
on how you said certain things.
So, even though maybe what you said
from a content perspective
made absolute sense,
the way how you phrased it, how
you structured your message,
this is something that
as a young consultant
you will get tons of feedback in in most
of the large strategy consulting firms.
And the reason I believe is quite obvious
because in many ways it is not always
just about what you say,
but also how you convey your message.
To what extent you are
able to actually persuade
the other person that
what you say is correct.
To what extent you help the other person
to actually remember the
message points that you have,
and then be able to also to tell these
two or three key arguments to other people
in an organization in an
intuitive and persuading way.
So, what consultancies commonly do
to train the junior consultants
in these training programs
to do role plays, and these role plays
frequently go something like this, right?
You are being asked to
imagine yourself sitting
in the team room somewhere at the client,
and now the client walks in,
and maybe even a board member,
or another senior leader
of the client organization
walks in and asks you,
"Hey Heinrich, how is it going?
"What is the status," right?
And often you're taken a bit off guard,
maybe you're in the middle
of doing something else,
and now the senior leader
or this board member
walks into your team room
and asks you to quickly
and to the point summarize
what exactly you're doing
and what the status is.
And as maybe you can imagine
this puts many people
into quite a high amount of stress,
and many people struggle to
in a precise and concise way
and actually summarize the
key results of the project
and give a concise and professional answer
to this question of the board member.
And in this video I will
bring up one of the points
that is really frequently
addressed in feedback sessions
after these role play situations.
And also in situations in real projects
where maybe indeed a senior
member of the client walks in,
and you then as a young
consultant say something
which may not have met the standards
of professional and concise communication.
One of the key points that
is brought up in these
kind of feedback sessions
is the distinction
between process and content
when you communicate.
When you answer such a question,
when you're asked to give a status report,
or asked to report on any project matter,
or any other business matter,
if you look at it in a stylized way
there are two ways how
you can talk about it.
It's either focused on the process
or it's focused on the content,
and let me explain to you
what exactly I mean by that.
So, let's start with process,
what does it mean if you talk process?
So, let's imagine that you've
been working on a project
that has been about sizing
market opportunities
in different countries.
So, your client or maybe
your team lead asked you
to analyze different geographies
and understand if there is a country
where it might make sense for your company
to enter the market with a certain product
that you as a compony are offering.
So, if your communication
focuses a lot on process,
this means that you focus a
lot on the different steps
that you took to get to a certain result.
So, you talk a lot about
what you actually did
in the last days, in the last
weeks, in the last months.
So, an example could be
something like this to say well,
I talked to the colleague
in the finance department
and then I got some numbers there.
And then I put some market reports
to actually combine the data,
and then I also looked into
macroeconomic information
about the different countries.
And then I combined these things,
but then I realized that actually
I'm missing certain information.
So, I went to the
marketing department head,
and then I talked to her to understand
her opinion about these geographies.
And then again I compiled it,
and then we had some alignment meetings
with other people of the organization.
And then on looking at all of this
this is the result that
we came up with, right?
So, this is a process-oriented
way of communicating,
and it focuses a lot on
the things that you did
in order to get to a certain result.
And many people like to
talk about the process.
This is something that many people
somehow naturally tend to,
to talk about the process.
And probably due to the fact
that it really underlines
what all the effort is that
you put into something.
It underlines that you
really spent lots of time
on a certain task.
It underlines that you
really worked a lot,
that there were just many,
many things that you did,
and you really made a big
and significant effort
to solve this problem.
But I hope that you also see the downsides
of talking about things in this way
because the focus is on
the steps that you took,
but the focus is not on results.
And now try to put yourself
into the shoes of a CEO
of a large blue-chip company,
and you can assume that
he assumes that usually
the people he works with are professionals
and that they will make
sure that the things
that they present to
him meet a certain level
of quality and of analytical rigor.
And the truth is the CEO of such a company
just will not care about all
the meetings that you had,
all the time that you put into something,
all of the analysis that you took
and then maybe found out that
this actually didn't work
so that then you needed to
look into something else,
and this then maybe worked or not.
The CEO will not care, okay?
He does not care about all
the sweat, all the work,
all the hours you put into something.
What he cares about is the result,
and if you talk so much about the process
you will just waste his time.
And this is something
you should be very cautious
about to not waste the time
of your coworkers,
especially if you operate
in such a professional environment.
So, this is now the process-oriented way
of talking about something.
Let's now look into the
content-oriented way.
How would you phrase an
answer to the question
of what you did on a project in a way
that actually focuses
much more on the content
but not so much on the process?
And talking about content basically means
talking about the results.
So, let me give you an example.
What would that mean
to talk about results?
So, if you talk about the content
you could tell your CEO something like,
so from the analysis that
we did so far we conclude
that France likely is
the country where for us
it would make most sense to
enter with this new product
that we have, and for three reasons.
First, consumer research
shows that this product
really meets the needs of French consumers
in a way that it is not the same
with the consumer behavior patterns
that we see in other countries.
The second reason is that
the competitive situation
in these countries is that currently
there is no strong competitor there
offering a similar product.
So, if we go there now
we have an advantage
because we are the first,
and we can now quickly
grow in market share
before maybe others then
join the market later.
The third reason is that our operations
are very well set up to
enter the French market
because we have warehouses,
we have a supply chain set
up that is very effective
in serving the French
market at the moment.
And it's much better suited
for the French market
than compared to other markets
which might be served instead.
So, now let's make a cut here.
This is just an example
of how you could phrase
such an answer that now much
more focuses on the content.
Of course now the arguments
that I said were arbitrary
and depend on the specific
situation that you're in,
but I hope that you see the difference
that what I did not do is explaining
what all the steps were,
what all the data is that I analyzed,
what the meetings were that I had.
What maybe first I thought,
but then I needed to revise
because I found out that
it doesn't make sense
and something else actually
makes much more sense.
All of the things I did not talk about,
but what I did talk about
is what the result is
and what the key arguments are
that actually back up this result.
And now ask yourself
what would be the answer
that the CEO likely would
be much more interested in?
And from my experience in working
for several years in consulting
I can tell you that the
latter is the proper answer
to give in these situations.
The latter answer is an answer
that somebody who communicates
professionally and effectively will give.
So, talking about the content
is really the way to go,
I cannot stress this enough.
Communication is so crucial in
any professional environment,
and focusing on content instead of process
when talking about things that you did,
when giving status updates,
when talking about your projects,
when talking about the things
that you're working on is really crucial
and distinguishes you as a
professional communicator.
And of course now I talked a
lot about consulting examples,
I talked a lot about
the consulting context,
but the truth is that this
type of communication behavior
is relevant to pretty much
any job that you have.
It really does not depend at all
in which industry you're in,
making sure that you focus
on professional communication
is absolutely key.
And what you'll notice,
even when you work in
large blue-chip companies,
that a lot of people really struggle
with good and effective communication.
Even senior leaders of
some of these companies
really struggle with
effective communication.
This is something where
you can actually improve
very quickly and make a difference,
and just shine in contrast
to all these other people.
And the key phrase that just summarizes
this kind of communication pattern,
so if you're looking for
a name for all of this
to do further research it's
called top-down communication.
Top-down communication is the holy grail
in professional communication.
And what I just talked about,
the distinction between
process and content,
is just one aspect of it.
There are many other aspects
in top-down communication.
So, I'd like to hear from you.
Are you interested to learn more
about what professional
communication is all about?
Let me know and I might
cover other aspects
of this type of communication
in future videos.
And just as a quick tip if you just want
to get started right away,
the Bible of this top-down
communication approach
is a book that is called
"The Pyramid Principle" by Barbara Minto.
It's a book that at least at McKinsey
almost every consultant reads,
and some training programs
you even get it as a gift
as something you're supposed
to read in order to advance.
And I could highly communicate this book.
I will leave a link to this
book in the description below,
so if you're interested just check it out.
So, let me know if you would
like to see more videos
on effective communication
in this channel.
So, if you took any value
out of this video at all
please press the Like
button and subscribe,
and also press the Notification bell
to keep up to date with
my channel's content.
I will release at least
one video every week,
often even two videos,
so subscribe to stay posted.
I will bring you lots of
content on how to be successful
in the first years in your
career drawn from my experience
at McKinsey and also working
in a senior leadership position
in a German retailer.
Let me know if you have any
questions in the comments.
I will do my very best to give an answer
to every single comment that you write.
So, I hope you're all doing
well and had a good time.
Stay safe, keep learning,
and thank you for watching.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.